>> Alright. So is this, is it clear what these answers are?
>> Let's find out. So, let's see. we, we already worked out
the math on this. So we know that, for gamma, greater than
1 6th, cooperating is better than defecting, in general. So if I'm
going against someone who's always going to
cooperate, then I should always cooperate.
>> Incorrect.
>> What?
>> Yes, so, so, we didn't actually work that out. What we worked
out was what to do if you were playing against tit for tat.
If you were playing against someone who was
always cooperating, and is completely oblivious to us.
>> No, no, no, no, no, you're right. You should
always defect because you're always going to win. Yes, yes, yes.
>> You're always going to win. You're going to get zero on every time step.
>> Right, right.
>> Yeah.
>> No, that makes sense. That's beautiful.
>> Alright, what about always defect?
>> Well, if you're always going to defect, you might as well defect.
>> Indeed.
>> because we're just in the regular old prisoner's dilemma world. [LAUGH]
>> good,
alright. So now we, now we have this, this other strange beast here.
So our opponent is playing tit for tat. So we could always defect.
>> Right.
>> But we would do, we'd get a higher score
if we can convince tit for tat to cooperate with us.
>> For a gamma greater than a 6th.
>> That's right.
>> So that you should always cooperate.
>> That is true, however.
>> Mm-hm.
>> What if we played tit for tat against tit for tat.
>> You'll end up in the same place.
>> Yeah,
so that's just as good.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that's, that's kind of interesting.
If you think about mutual best responses.
>> Yes.
>> So that's a strategy that, a pair of strategies where each is a best
response to the other, there's a, we
have another name for that. Do you remember?
>> No.
>> [LAUGH] You taught, you told us what it was.
>> Yeah, but I probably used different words.
>> It's, it's a Nash equilibrium.
>> Oh.
>> This, that's what a Nash equilibrium is. A pair
of strategies where each is a best response to the other. Each, ea there's
no way that either would prefer to
switch to something else to get higher reward.
>> And that makes perfect sense. You're in
an equilibrium. And that is a Nash equilibrium. Okay.
>> So we can use this little table here
to actually identify Nash equilibrium. So, what would a
strategy be? So, so if one player plays always
cooperate, then the best response to that is always defect.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But the best response to always defect, is always
defect. So always cooperate is not part of a Nash equilibrium.
>> Right.
>> But what about always defect versus always defect?
>> No, it is.
>> So that's a Nash. Right?
>> Yep.
>> Because they're both doing the thing
that is the best response to the other.
>> Right.
>> Alright, this box here, always cooperate
against tit for tat. That's not okay,
because if a player does always cooperate,
it's always better to switch to always defect.
>> Yep.
>> But,
check this out. If you are playing tit for tat,
and the other player's playing tit for tat, there's no reason
to switch because it's actually a best response, it's the
optimal thing to do. And that works from both players' perspectives.
>> And that makes sense. So like you said check this
out and you've been using check marks that's very good. [LAUGH].
>> So we're in this situation where we have two Nash equilibria.
>> Indeed, and one of these Nash equilibria, [NOISE]
is cooperative. Which is the thing that we were
sad about, or at least that I was feeling really sad
about, in the, in the last lesson. The idea that, man,
there's just, it's clear that they should just try to get
along. You explained that you can modify the reward structure, and
then they would get along better. But here it turns out,
well, no, another thing you can do is just open it
up to the possibility of playing multiple rounds, as long as
you don't know how many rounds, it becomes possible to to
have a strategy that is best off cooperating, and is in fact a Nash Equilibrium.
>> Isn't that equivalent to changing the reward structure?
>> It's definitely related to changing the reward
structure. It's a particular way of changing it.
>> A very particular way.
>> But it's. Yeah, because it's not true any more that we can do this
in the one shot case. You have to be in the, in the repeated game, setting.
>> Right, so you change your rewards structure to be a sum of
rewards. But it's actually an expected sum of rewards, and you don't know
where it is you're going to stop. So I guess you're changed, you're changed
the game, you changed the, the rewards. But in a, sort of very subtle way.
>> Yeah, the whole game is different, really.
>> Yeah man, you changed the game. [LAUGH].
>> Sometimes you gotta change the game. Don't hate the game.
>> No, you are supposed to hate the
game. Don't hate the player, hate the game.